I pledge to withdraw from the Colorado
GOP Primary ballot unless and until TR
Trump's name is
restored and I demand that Ronda sanis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same thing or else these Republicans
are simply complicit in this
unconstitutional attack on the way we
conduct our constitutional republic
unpopular opinion I realize on the right
anyway but I don't really you know I I
don't like this move from thec I like a
lot of what he does and says on this one
I I don't see it I don't get it um I
mean first of all Trump is still on the
ballot because the decision has been
stayed and it'll be overturned so maybe
it's all like it's maybe kind of a mood
point in that sense but at the same time
I don't see how you punish the left and
these activist judges by voluntarily
withdrawing from the ballot as a
Republican